[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREA BRIMMER: That is
a-- that is a very nice
welcome, very nice.
I appreciate it.
Very spontaneous, so thank you.
Thanks, Jess, for
having me here today.
I appreciate it.
So what I wanted to
chat a little bit
with you guys about
today-- and first of all,
thank you for having me here.
I'm excited to be here--
is the importance of
bravery in marketing
and why that's so
important, really,
in today's marketing landscape
and in the world that
is, really, so focused
on technology and data
and how we intercept the art
and the science of marketing.
And if you look at just
the technical definition
of bravery, it's this idea
of the quality or state
of having or showing mental or
moral strength to face danger,
fear, or difficulty.
So those are really powerful
words when you think about them
in the business context,
but from the lens of a CMO,
why are they so important?
Well, they're important
for a number of reasons.
First and foremost, the CMO
seat, especially these days,
is a hot seat.
The average tenure
for a CMO is 18 months
according to a
recent study, and I'm
going to talk a little
bit more about this.
But 80% of CEOs
actually say that they
don't trust their CMO,
and we'll get into that.
But having bravery
is a path forward.
This idea of kind of facing
danger, fear, or difficulty,
I think, aligns really
well with this idea
that I'm talking about.
And I think, in a
world where people
are so overwhelmed with choice,
and people have so little time
in their day anymore,
that you have
to be brave to breakthrough,
and as marketers, that's
what we're really trying to do.
We're trying to break through
and make emotional engagements
with people, and it's more
difficult than ever before.
And I think we know a
little bit about bravery,
if you think about my
company, Ally Financial,
and what we did.
So think about the fact
that, like you guys,
we're a pretty young company.
10 years ago, we
didn't even exist,
which is hard to believe.
And what we did is we launched
in the worst financial crisis
since the Great Depression.
We were spun off
from General Motors.
We were GMs captive
auto finance company,
and GM was going through
its bankruptcy and needed
liquidity.
And so the idea was to sell the
captive, and all of a sudden,
we found ourselves
in a marketplace
where we had been engineered
and built to do one thing,
and that was to serve
auto loans to GM dealers.
Suddenly, we're in this
complete financial crisis,
where is, markets
are crashing down.
There's no access to liquidity.
We have no mother ship anymore.
GM is gone, and we
had to change or die.
And we had thousands of people
that were depending on us,
as employees of Ally.
But bigger than that,
we had 17,000 dealers
that were dependent
on us to survive,
and we had, really,
the responsibility
of a huge impact on the American
economy if GMAC went down.
And so what we had to do
is start from scratch,
and we had to rethink the
way that we were going
to go to market completely.
And we really felt like
there's this huge opportunity,
and everybody was saying to
us, what are you going to do?
And our thought was, we're
going to launch a bank,
and the bank is going to
become the deposit gathering
capability that will
fund the auto loans.
And we'll kind of
reinvent ourselves
to be able to have the
ability to do that.
And we're not going to
just create a normal bank.
We're going to create a
digital bank because we needed
to get to market quickly.
We didn't have time
for infrastructure
to build brick and
mortar locations,
and we were on a
very short time frame
in order to be able to
start generating revenue
before our liquidity ran out.
Complicating that is the
government came to us and said,
we're going to close
down Chrysler Capital,
and we want you to take on all
the Chrysler dealers as well.
So that added significant
pressure to our timeline
and to what it was
that we needed to do.
And everybody was
saying, a bank?
The world doesn't
need another bank.
That's the last thing anybody
wants is another bank.
And our mantra at the
time was this notion
that, yeah, the world
doesn't need another bank,
but it needs a better bank.
And we took this bet that
everybody would be banking
in the palm of their hand.
Now, it seems really
intuitive now, 10 years later,
as you watch all these
big companies scramble
to get to digital financial
services solutions,
but 10 years ago,
there was nobody out
in the category like us.
We also saw a ton of pain
points in the category.
People were either
completely apathetic.
They weren't paying
any attention
to how their banks
were treating them.
And if you think about
it, in a lot of ways,
we were putting up with
things that, as consumers, we
shouldn't be putting up with.
Why should I pay $5 to get
my money out of the wall?
Think about it.
You still do it today.
Why do I have my money
sitting in a bank that doesn't
pay any interest on my savings?
People still do it today.
Why can't I have
24 by 7 service?
Money's a really
important thing.
I work really hard for my money.
My family depends on my money.
Yet if it's past 5 o'clock or 6
o'clock, and something happens,
I can't talk to
anybody at a bank.
Why is everything so confusing?
Why is the jargon so confusing?
Why do banks purposely try and
confuse you and hide things
from you, whether they're hidden
fees, this bait and switch
mentality?
So a lot of pain
points, and we really
felt like there was this huge
opportunity and a better way
forward, and that really
is what created Ally.
So literally, in a
six-month period of time,
back during that
financial crisis,
a very small group
of us pretty much
spent the whole entire
summer in New York
with a branding company
and an advertising agency,
and we came up with
what we thought
was a better way forward.
And we created Ally.
The launch was really different.
We really took on the big banks.
What we wanted to do was
of create this awakening.
We wanted to reach out
and shake people and get
them to pay attention and
get them to pay attention
to what was happening
in the category
and, also, what
was paying-- what
was happening to their money.
And so we launched in a really
loud and disruptive way.
And as a marketer at the
time, this was really
a brave campaign, and I'll talk
a little bit about how it did.
I'll talk a little bit
about some of the reaction
and some of the things
that occurred as a result.
But the whole business model
itself was brave, but also
the way that we came
to market, I think,
is a great example of that.
So let me play a couple of spots
that you guys may or may not
remember.
This is the way that
Ally came to market.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Have some fun with that truck.
- Vroom, vroom.
- OK, time's up.
Here you go.
That's a nice one.
I made that.
- A piece of junk.
I want the red truck.
- Well, you can't
have the red truck.
See, that was a limited
time offer only.
It's right here
in the fine print.
- Even kids know it's wrong
to hide behind fine print.
Why don't banks?
We're Ally-- a new
bank whose rates
will always be among
the top with nothing
buried in the fine print.
It's just the right thing to do.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Would you like a pony?
- Yeah.
[CLICKING HIS TONGUE]
- Here you go.
This is for you.
- Wow!
That's fun.
- Yeah.
- You didn't say I
could have a real one.
- Well, you didn't ask.
- Even kids know it's wrong
to hold out on somebody.
Why don't banks?
We're Ally-- a new
bank that alerts you
when your money can be working
harder and earning more.
It's just the right thing to do.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ANDREA BRIMMER: So
a really bold way
to come to market in a
category that had always
done just really boring, really
plain type of advertising.
Everything about what we did
was brave, including the color--
a purple bank.
I mean, what we did is
we put, up on the wall,
all bank advertising,
and everything
was either red, white, or blue.
If you think about it,
like look around today,
you'll see the same thing.
And so we thought,
we want to stand out.
We're going to be
a digital bank.
We want to do
something different,
and we chose the color purple.
These spots-- the idea was
RJ represented the big banks,
and we wanted to
clearly call out
how dishonorably banks
were behaving and the fact
that even little kids recognize
when something is wrong.
Everything was
shot hidden camera.
All the cameramen were
in those play structures
that you saw in the
background there.
The kids thought that they were
coming in for focus groups,
and we got real reactions.
And they just blew up.
I mean, it resonated.
It created that emotional
connection with people
right away.
I remember shooting
the one with a pony,
and we shot a bunch
of different kids
just to get the best reactions.
And we shot these two
sisters, and they came in,
and they did the--
RJ did the, do you want a
pony, yes, do you want a pony.
And I was sitting with
her mom in the green room,
and when the other
sister got the real pony,
the other little
sister turned to her
and punched her
right in the face.
I was like, I really
want to use that one,
but we decided to go
with this one instead.
But it was a really great
way for us to come to market.
And it really helped
us build a brand,
and it helped us get in the--
get on the landscape very,
very quickly.
And if you kind of fast
forward now, 10 years later,
and look at how we--
how we've done, it's
been unbelievable.
We have 1.4 million
customers of Ally bank.
On the auto side, 4 and
1/2 million customers,
so all totaled, about
5 and 1/2 million
customers that we do
business with today.
In 10 years, nine-- almost $95
billion in deposits, and this
is for something where
there's no brick and mortar.
People are just
interacting with us online,
and we've grown to
be a top 25 bank.
Our bank CEO was named one of
the top 10 most powerful women
in banking last year,
and we've built a company
from the ground up by
being brave and going
to market in a
very different way
and creating something where
we saw a ton of whitespace
and a ton of
opportunity in a time
where there was a category
that needed to be disrupted
and a category that
needed to be shaken up.
The other thing that
we've done along the way
is we've built this
incredibly magical brand.
And our CEO talks about his
six strategic priorities,
and the one thing that he
talks about in his priorities
is brand as a weapon.
And I think that's a huge
testament to what we've
done from a marketing
perspective,
because marketing's been
a catalyst for helping
build this brand,
and then having
the right internal inertia,
much like you guys do,
to back up the promise of
what the brand stands for.
A couple of years ago,
Boston Consulting Group
did a list of the up and
coming brands to watch,
and it was Hulu, it was Tesla,
it was GoPro, it was Snapchat,
it was Airbnb, and Ally.
No other banks on that list,
and no Fortune 500 companies
on that list.
Last year, Gale and Seigel did
a list of their top disruptor
brands, and same kind of list--
Uber and GrubHub and Airbnb
and Spotify and Ally.
So very different
kinds of brands,
but it underscores
what we've done
and how we've been disruptive
and how we've used bravery
to really create an entirely new
category on something, if you
think about it, that's been
around for over 100 years.
So as we kind of
fast forward now,
10 years later, and look at
where we're at, last year,
we made a big strategic pivot.
And we decided that we were
going to expand our product
portfolio.
Given how much consumers
really like doing business
with us on the banking side,
and the fact that we only
had savings products, we
wanted to expand rapidly.
So we launched-- we
bought a company,
and we launched an all
online investing platform, so
self-directed and
managed portfolios.
We stood up, very quickly,
a mortgage capability.
We partnered with
another company,
and we stood up a credit card.
And we purchased a
company in California
to do direct to consumer auto
lending, kind of like a Lending
Tree model, but to
have the ability
to be able to reach
into consumers
and not just have to
work with the dealers
on indirect lending, but give us
that indirect lending platform.
We're also in the process of
completely reinventing our auto
business to be the digital
choice for dealers.
As dealer's businesses
are transforming,
and that category
is finally starting
to catch up to the rest
of the retail world,
how do we power
dealers so that any way
that a consumer wants to
interact with them digitally,
we can be at the center
of those interactions,
giving them what they need
from a lending standpoint?
So this necessitated
a change in pace
in terms of how we
are going to market.
And again, we needed
to be very disruptive,
and we needed to be very brave.
We're in a category
that spends ferociously.
The financial services
category spends over $2 billion
a year on advertising,
and where less than 2%
share a voice in that category.
So for me, the
challenge was how do we
outwit, outlast, and outplay?
How do we break
through and do things
that are very different
than what everybody else is
doing in the category?
So we repositioned
ourselves, moving
to this positioning
of a relentless ally
for your financial well-being,
and we created a campaign
that we wanted to
humanize ourselves.
Since we didn't have
brick and mortar,
and people couldn't
walk into a branch,
we wanted to do something
that was fun, something that
was differentiated, that
showed that people of Ally
being relentless and
going over the top
and doing things in a
really interesting way
for our customers.
So we tried to be disruptive
in literally everything we did.
We used disruptive creative.
I'm going to show you
a couple of pieces
of creative in a second.
Really changed up our look in
terms of our graphic design
and our visual look.
I mean, when you look at
this plum and our people
in the advertising
and the headlines,
they have that clever wit,
and they just broke through.
They weren't like
anything else that you
were seeing in our
category, or really
in any other category
for that matter.
We used really
differentiated media,
so we partnered with a
lot of content providers
that we had never
partnered with before--
Pop Sugar and Vice.
We did a really cool
promotion called
Lucky Penny, where we actually
got this idea that people
hate pennies.
The US government is thinking
about not minting pennies
anymore.
They stopped minting
pennies in Canada.
I get them, and
I throw them out.
Or you always leave them in that
little jar at the convenience
store because no one wants
to carry them around.
And so we wanted
to create something
interesting around
this idea that a penny
saved is a penny earned, and
that even the smallest amount
of savings can go a long way.
And so we hid 10
pennies in 10 cities
across the country,
each worth $1,000.
They were Ally branded pennies,
and we used social media
to push out clues about
where those pennies were.
And we created this unbelievable
groundswell of activity
around people getting
together and trying
to go find those pennies, and
the stories that came out of it
were unbelievable.
And it got so big that
Jimmy Kimmel actually
did a segment on it where
Guillermo actually went outside
in LA, set up a tent,
and had people come in,
where he had a sign
outside that said
"A penny for your thoughts."
And they filmed all this
really funny content of people
coming in, asking
Guillermo a question,
him answering the question
with something outrageous that
made literally no sense,
collecting all these pennies,
and then looking for
the Ally lucky penny.
So these were ways where we were
able to get our brand in front
of people in really different
and unique use of media.
We created a lot of really
interesting partnerships,
partnered with influencers
that we had never
partnered with before,
people like Big and Rich,
who are very differentiated
people in the country music
space, that do
things their own way;
and Danny Coker,
who sponsored ICC,
which is the international
soccer friendlies.
We even created an entire
fragrance line around the idea
that people's favorite smell
is the smell of a new car.
So we created a
line of fragrances
called New Car Smell, and we
had 15 different fragrances
that we displayed
at auto shows that
were all around this idea of
SUV smell and minivan smell.
We had people walking around
auto shows with scent strips,
handing them out, just like
you go into a department store.
You had the ability, on an
iPad, to create your own scent,
and then we surprised 50
people from each auto show,
and we actually made
their scent and sent it
to them, so really
just different ways
to go out and do
interesting things.
We created something called
our Disruptor Calendar,
and we did things
like Lucky Penny.
We created an app called
Splurge Alert app,
and what you did with the
Splurge Alert app is you
actually downloaded the app.
And then you could go into
it, and you put into the app
what your financial
kryptonite is.
So for me, it might be
Nordstrom's or a Prada store,
a car dealership,
or a wine store.
And then we geofence
those locations,
and every time you walked
into one of those locations,
you got an alert from
the Ally Splurge Alert
app that would say, Andrea,
get the hell out of there.
Last time you were there,
it was a bad scene.
And they were all
really fun and humorous.
And then you actually got
to pick splurge buddies,
and it pushed an alert
to your splurge buddies--
kind of like AA,
not that I'd know.
And those people could text you
and say, what are you doing?
You're saving for
your kids college.
Get out of Nordstrom.
So it was a really
fun way to get
people to think
about their money
differently without
preaching to them.
And then we really went
on the offensive with PR.
We had never really used earned
media as anything but reactive,
and so we went out
and got very, I
think, differentiated
and brave in terms
of what we were doing with PR.
One of the things that
we did that was just
really interesting is
we-- we're an online bank.
And if you're an
online bank, your phone
needs to be charged
at every moment
because, if you want to
interact with your money,
you need a phone that's working.
So we actually had drones that
were branded with the Ally
logo, and we passed out
phone chargers in malls
through these drones.
And it was just a
really cool way--
they were Ally
branded phone charges,
and we got a ton of PR out
of it, a lot of earned media.
And it was a really
interesting and disruptive way
to do something different.
Now, the one common
thread that I can tell you
through all of this is
that, every single point
of it, somebody told me
how dumb the idea was.
Somebody told me that
it was a dangerous thing
to do for our brand.
Somebody told me
why it would fail.
Somebody told me why
we shouldn't do it.
And the one thing that we
did the entire way is we
filtered out the noise.
And we put our heads down,
and we used the golden gut.
And we believed in what we were
doing, and we pushed forward.
I can't tell you how many
things like the Splurge Alert
app, where somebody
said to me, what's
the business case for this?
Let me see what the ROI's
going to be on this.
What are your KPIs?
And that's the world
we live in today.
Everything's testable,
and everybody wants
to know what the data says.
And while you have to use
the data to make informed
decisions, you can't
let the data prevent you
from doing things that you know
are the right things to do.
And you have to forge
forward, and you
have to take the
consequences good or bad.
Not everything that
we did was awesome.
we did was successful,
but the vast majority of
what we did was successful.
We have our highest
brand awareness
that we've had in our
company's history.
Our brand engagement scores went
from 43% to over 90% right now.
Our likability scores
are all in the 90s.
Our business has
never been better.
Our stock was at $15 a share
when we started this campaign.
It's near $30 a share a
year and a half later.
So I encourage you guys to
think about the importance
of bravery, filter out the
noise, and just push forward
and do what you need to do.
I'm going to play
the launch spot that
launched the new campaign.
I think, when you
see it, I think
it's great testament
of what I'm talking
about relative to
doing things different
in this banking space.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Remember, here
at Ally, nothing
stops us from doing
right by our customers.
Who's with me?
- I'm in.
- [INAUDIBLE].
[MUSIC PLAYING - MOTLEY CRUE
"KICKSTART MY HEART"]
- One!
Two!
Wait.
Wait, where's Tina?
- Doing the hand thing?
- Yep!
- We're all in
for our customers.
Ally-- do it right.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ANDREA BRIMMER: So everyone
was like Motley Crue?
Are you kidding me?
Even our board was like,
I think the lead singer
died from a drug overdose.
I'm like, everybody died
from a drug overdose, then.
I mean, who are we going
to find that didn't?
A really different way to come
to market, a really different
way to reposition our
brand, show are people doing
over-the-top things,
and just have fun,
and what ended up happening
as a result of this spot,
is it caught fire.
And everybody in
social was talking
about doing the hand thing,
and so we stoked the fire
by immediately jumping on
it and having a contest
and telling people to send
in their best content of them
doing the hand thing.
And then we surprised
and delighted
people with different prizes for
the best pictures or the best
content that came in.
So again, just doing things
differently, being brave,
and getting outside
of the space.
Recently, we did something
around the Super Bowl
that I wanted to show you guys.
This was, I think,
another moment
of bravery, which is this
idea that everybody can buy--
every big marketer can buy
a spot in the Super Bowl
if they want.
But for us, we felt like it was
duplicitous to spend a couple
million on a spot
in the Super Bowl
when we're out there telling
our customers to think
about having a savings mindset.
So we wanted to take
advantage of the biggest
day of consumerism
by intercepting
it and interrupting it
in a really unique way.
So I'm going to show you a
video that I think will give you
a good sense of it, and
we'll talk a little bit
about how it did
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- (WHISPERING) Oh, gosh.
- I want my children to
know that they always
have a place to come back to.
- Something needed
to be done about what
was going on in our inner city.
- When she got injured,
it was upsetting.
- Giving back to them
with whatever I earned
is one of my top priorities.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ANDREA BRIMMER: So again, a very
different way to go to market.
In a time when all brands are
spending millions of dollars
to get you to buy a bag of
Doritos or a Mountain Dew
by producing giant television
spots, we did something,
I think, much
different than that,
and we created this
virtual reality app.
And again, a lot of
questions around it.
What if the app doesn't work?
What if it crashes that night?
What if other brands
are mad at us?
Because the app only activated
during the commercial breaks,
so that was the only
time that you could play.
We were taking eyes away from
the investment that people
had in their Super Bowl spots.
And again, there
was some risk to it.
We had never done
it we didn't know
how the technology would work.
Mercedes had a bit of a fiasco
with a virtual reality idea
during the Super Bowl, and
for us, it turned out awesome.
We had a million
and a half people
that came to our microsite.
We were number two most
downloaded app that week
in your store.
We were number four on Apple.
We had 70,000
downloads of the app.
We had 660,000 rounds
of the game played.
And what we did is we had
the top 15 scores submitted.
And we selected the best
stories and the high scores,
merged those two
together, and we
granted those people's wishes.
And now, we're getting the
outgrowth of all of the PR
that went along with that.
And I think just to
punctuate the different way
that we went to market on
this, our CEO last week
wrote a handwritten note to
each one of the Big Save winners
and congratulated every single
one of them on behalf of Ally.
So a really cool way to,
again, be brave, disrupt,
and do something
really different,
especially in the face of
a lot of people saying, why
are you doing this,
and I don't think it's
the right thing to do.
I'm not to go through
all of this in detail,
but I've been doing
a presentation,
and just part of it, when we
are together, in December.
But these are the
kinds of things
that I think CMOs have
their eyes on right now,
and these are the kinds of
things that keep us up at night
as we think about the best way
to come to market and marketing
in this brave new world.
I always say to my team,
marketing's changed more
in the last five years than
it's changed in probably the 25
years preceding
that, and we have
to be on a constant
learning agenda.
I would say I probably spend 2/3
of my time doing my actual job,
and a third of my time
on this learning agenda.
And it's really the reign of
digital disruption and the way
that people are
interacting with brands
that has changed the way that
we have to behave as marketers.
And you look at some
of these things--
personalized
omnichannel experiences,
this idea that people want
to be able to interact
with your brand regardless of
which device they come in on.
You guys know that, but
for a lot of big brands
that are in the
e-commerce space,
it's a really hard thing to
get right, this idea of speed
is of the essence and how
impatient people have become.
The attention span now
of the average consumer
is eight seconds.
I read a statistic the other
day that was staggering,
that because of technology
and the ability technology
has given us to multitask,
the average person
packs 34 hours of activity
into a 12-hour day.
That's staggering.
So as marketers, how do we
get people's thumbs to stop?
How do we get people to look up?
How do we get people
to pay attention?
Keeping customer attention,
not losing people, this idea
of relevance versus cool--
we argue about
this all the time.
What's more important--
to be a cool brand,
or to be a relevant brand?
And our thought is relevant
because the definition of cool
is changing all the time.
I think about this idea
that, with all this data
like I talked about, with all
this reliance and everybody's
first response
always being, well,
that's a testable
proposition, brand matters.
85% of people still say that
their purchases are driven
by an emotional connection,
and that they'll
spend more money to do
business with the brand
that they have an
emotional connection with.
So as a CMO, continuing to
drive that is really important.
And then the last one on
here, which is, I think,
a new and emerging
one that takes
an incredible amount of bravery
is this idea of taking a stand.
It's really interesting,
in the political climate
that we're in right now,
people are personifying brands.
They expect us to have
an opinion on things,
and it doesn't matter which side
of the fence that you're on.
But with all the issues
that are emerging,
with all of the movements
with a lot of the vitriol
that's being spewed
in the political
climate, people want
to know where brands stand.
And it's not OK to
be neutral anymore.
You can't take a pass.
But how do you keep
your brand safe?
When you're wearing two hats
like me, as marketing and PR,
how do I keep my
CO out of hot water
when consumers want to
know where he personally
stands on gun safety?
How do we keep our
company safe when
people want to know where we
stand on large societal issues?
It's a really interesting
space that we've never
had to deal with before.
Five years ago, people
didn't care what
brands thought about stuff.
Now, they won't do
business with you
if you don't have an opinion
on things, so bravery, I think,
is more important
than ever before.
And for me-- and I think
this is probably a good segue
into the questions--
bravery's just
never been a choice.
It's always been a way of life.
I recently got remarried in
December, but prior to that,
I had been a single
mom for about 15 years,
raising two boys.
And how do you work
and raise two boys
and have the bravery, when
you're in an important job,
to stand up in the middle
of a meeting and say,
I've got to go to my son's
hockey game, and I'm leaving?
I've always been a woman
in an industry full of men,
whether it was automotive
or financial services.
It was always me and all the
guys sitting around the table.
And it's just different
for a woman in business,
and we'll probably talk a little
bit more about that as well.
But having the bravery
to stay true to who I am
and stay true to
what I believe in,
but also being able to
interact in that setting
and around those
tables, and then always
having big responsibility
at very young ages.
A guy and I were
laughing a little bit
before we came in
here, of maybe a lot
of it is just people haven't
caught up with me yet
or figured it out.
But I had my second son.
I was, I think, 35 years old.
I came back from
maternity leave.
I had two kids under two years
old, and all of a sudden,
I was the account director
on the Chevrolet account
at Campbell Ewald, the
youngest person ever,
the only woman in the '99
year history of the account.
And I found myself
kind of thrust
into a really interesting
space at a very young age.
And how do you have that
credibility, and how
do you maneuver through that?
And for me, it just always
returned to that one thing,
and it was that idea of
being brave and saying
what was on my mind
and having a voice
and not being afraid to
push on the issues that
were important to me and
not being afraid to say,
I am what I am, and if
people don't like it,
then I'm probably not
right in this culture,
and I'm not right in this job.
And knowing that you can't
operate in a world of fear,
that you have to operate
from a position of strength,
and I've always governed
myself by this saying that good
is the enemy of great.
And I guess that's what I
want to leave you guys with,
is always push for great.
Bravery is that spine that
runs through all of it,
but just remember, it's OK.
You can always find another job.
You're going to be OK.
But at the end of the day,
when your career is over,
you want to be able
to look at yourself
and have integrity and know
that you did things the way
you wanted to do
things, and you always
stayed true to who you were.
So hopefully, you got,
out of the examples
and the things I talked
about, why it's so important.
I think you're at
a perfect company
to continue to
have this bravery,
to lead the charge in
the advancements of where
this crazy reign of
digital disruption is going
and to never forget
about staying
true to what your culture
means and what it means to you
and why you're here.
So I thank you guys.
Despite all the technical
glitches, we got through it,
and I appreciate your patience.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you--
ANDREA BRIMMER: Thank you.
SPEAKER: So much for
joining us and talking
about what brave means to you.
ANDREA BRIMMER: My pleasure.
SPEAKER: I think one of
the biggest things that,
as a company, that
we can take away
is the fact about
the golden gut.
The golden gut-- I haven't
heard that used in a long time,
but it's so true, that gut
feeling of what's really right
versus wrong, rather than
always being about the data.
As a big data company, I think
we get stuck with ourselves,
with clients, a lot of
different audiences about it
has to be data, data,
data, and we never use us.
ANDREA BRIMMER: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Can you
provide an example
of when you had to really
go more with your gut
than what the data
was telling you?
ANDREA BRIMMER:
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, that first campaign
that I showed you guys, truck
and pony, the visceral reaction
from people was, it's mean.
You're being mean
to the little kids.
You shouldn't take
on the big banks.
You're going to really
piss everybody off.
Isn't there was softer
way to come into this?
Why do you have to go out and
poke the bear, if you will?
And it required
a lot of bravery.
It required us, as
a marketing team,
to unite and come together
and say, if you really
want to make impact, if you
really want to change things,
you've got to go this direction.
And I knew there was
a lot of risk in it.
I mean, the reality was, if it
failed, I'd probably get fired.
But it was OK because
we just felt like it
was the right thing to do.
And we pushed forward, and
honestly, to this day--
it's 10 years later, and people
still talk about that campaign.
It really defined us.
It put us on the map.
And last year was the 10
year anniversary of it,
and we actually
brought the little kids
back now, 10 years later,
and with the launch
of the Do-It-Right campaign,
we said, all right,
we played a mean trick
on you at the time.
And now, we're going to
do things the right way,
and so we gave that
little girl a pony.
We gave her a real pony, and we
brought the monster truck kid
back.
And we-- actually
we blindfolded him,
and we had him in a giant
arena, kind of like Ford Field.
And when we took
the blindfold off
there was all these
monster trucks,
and we let him tear it up
in a bunch of monster trucks
for the afternoon, so
it's just a cool way
to bring it full circle.
SPEAKER: So with your teams,
though, and that golden gut,
do you have-- how
do you keep them
engaged on that, knowing
that the numbers are going
[INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREA BRIMMER: One, and
you'll find this odd,
but we don't pretest anything.
So I don't pretest any creative.
I don't believe in it.
Now, thankfully,
I have a CEO that
doesn't want to see pre-testing
and isn't really focused on it.
But there's a lot of
times where he'll say,
I don't think
that's a good spot,
and I don't think
we should do it.
But I trust your
opinion, and if you
want to go ahead and do it--
and I think my team sees that.
And I really think you
have to walk the walk
and talk the talk.
You can't talk
about being brave.
You can't talk about
doing things differently.
You can't talk about taking
risks unless you personally
take them, and I
think my team sees
me take them every single week.
Great example-- we're doing
agency reviews right now.
We put all our business up for
review, and I was with our CEO
last week in front of a
bunch of people from my team.
And he said, well,
why don't I fly out,
and I'll meet with some of
these agencies with you?
And I'll bring
Jen, who's our CFO.
And I said, no.
He was like, what?
I mean, this was in
front of everybody.
I said, I'm not going
to these agencies
with our CEO and the CFO.
They're never going to want
to do business with us.
And he's like, OK, fair enough.
You have to show your team
that you're brave enough,
and you've got the
passion, and then
I think people will follow.
SPEAKER: Well, I
think that fits really
good into my next
question about presence
and your ability just to be so
down to earth and so authentic.
It just draws people to you.
I mean, as you move
up in your career
and now are sitting
in the C-Suite,
it can be intimidating
for others.
But when I'm with you and
presented with you in front
of a bunch of
dealers, mind you, it
was like talking to
your best friend.
So I just would love
to hear about how you--
I mean, you've spoke about
it a little bit here,
but how you maintain
that and what-- why
that it's so important to you.
ANDREA BRIMMER: Well,
thank you, first of all.
I have a lot of sayings, but
another favorite saying of mine
is never drink
your own Kool-Aid.
And I hate-- as I grew up
in the agency business,
and I think a lot of you guys
probably have seen the same
thing--
as people get in
bigger and bigger jobs,
they become more
and more precious.
It's like our old CEO didn't
want any potato chips that
were brown, so his admin used
to pluck out the burnt potato
chips.
And I'm like, are
you kidding me?
And I've always
thought to myself,
if I ever get like that,
somebody please shoot me.
I never want to be that person.
So I've all-- and I also
know that a job can be over
like this, especially
in the C-Suite.
You look at things like
average tenure of a CMO--
18 months-- and you know.
You get a new CEO, or
you get a board member,
or you do something
and-- or the KPIs
aren't going in the right
direction, and you're out.
And so my belief is, if I
take myself too seriously,
and if I put off that
I'm a CMO, so I'm
better than everybody air,
nobody wants to be around me.
And who wants to be
around people like that?
It isn't very fun, and
it's not fun for me
either because I learn
from the people on my team
every single day.
And if they're intimidated
by being around me,
that's a bad place to be.
So I've always kind
of stayed true to that
never drink your own Kool-Aid.
Never let a job or
a career define you.
When I decide to
hang it up, I want
to be defined by
the kind of leader
I was, the kind of person I
was, the legacy that I left
on advertising and marketing,
and I want people to say,
she was a really cool chick.
I don't want them to say,
she was an arrogant idiot.
SPEAKER: I would
agree [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREA BRIMMER: Thank you.
SPEAKER: To, and speaking a
little bit to the last line
that you shared, I
mean, it's really
been amazing how
transparent you are
about who you were as a
mom, and raising these boys.
How would you say you
maintained that relationship
with your boys as they grew
and also this role so far?
ANDREA BRIMMER: Yeah,
everybody talks about balance.
Whoever came up with
the word imbalance,
I don't care if you're a
man or a woman in business,
there's no balance.
It's just-- it's ridiculous,
and it's fairy tale land
to believe that
you can achieve it.
And so for me, my thought
was always, I'm going to be--
I'm going to make
what I do matter.
And I have a platform where I
can make my sons into really
good men, and I can
give them experiences
that they could never get
if I didn't have this job.
And so a lot of what I
did is, first of all,
I picked the things that were
really important to them,
and I never missed those things.
So I think a good
example is when
my son was a senior
in high school,
he was on the
varsity hockey team,
and it was really important
to him that I was there,
and I travel a ton.
And I made a commitment to him
at the beginning of the season,
and I said, I'm not going
to miss any of your games.
And no matter what I had to do,
I made it to every single game.
Now, if any of you guys
are hockey parents,
you know you're
talking 60 games,
and I just established
that with my boss.
And I said, I'm not going
to miss any of his games.
So I'd literally be
on a three day trip,
and if he had a game on Tuesday,
I'd leave on Tuesday afternoon.
I'd fly to the game, and I'd
fly back either that night
or early the next morning.
The other thing
that I always did
is I brought my boys as
much as I could with me.
So when I traveled, I
brought them with me,
and they got to
see me in action.
I'd bring them to
things like this.
I still do.
I'd bring them to
interact with dealers.
They were always my
date for everything.
I was single, so it
was my two boys and me.
And they learned about
being in big cities.
They learned about
getting around airports.
They-- you can drop either
one of them in any situation,
and they're not
intimidated by it.
And then the time that
I was home with them,
I just was really
present in the moment.
My phone was down.
I wasn't on my computer.
And the time that
we had was for us,
and today, we have the
closest relationship.
And I've got two
stepkids now, and I'm
trying to do the
same thing with them
and just give them
an opportunity
to see the world
through my lens.
SPEAKER: That's super helpful.
Even for me, as my kids
are starting into school,
I used to try to be at
everything, and you just can't.
So really finding out what they
want you at or need you at--
ANDREA BRIMMER: You got
to give yourself a break.
I'll tell you-- women
have horrible guilt,
but I think this advice
goes for men or women.
Let yourself off the hook.
It's OK.
Do you think that, now
that my son's 21 years old,
he's ever going to remember
that I didn't go to one parent
teacher conference?
I didn't.
He doesn't talk about that.
When he's around his
friends, he talks about,
my mom's got this awesome
job, and she's a CMO,
and she's done this,
this, and this.
That's what he talks about,
and he talks about the things
that we've done together.
He doesn't talk about
those kinds of things.
So give yourself a break.
Be where you need
to be when you need
to be there, but a lot of that
stuff, don't worry about it.
They're never going to remember.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
ANDREA BRIMMER: Of course.
SPEAKER: One more
question before we'll
turn to the audience, about
Detroit, specifically.
So we know Ally has one
of the big buildings.
We see your big purple Ally
sign up on the Crown building.
We're coming down there, too.
ANDREA BRIMMER: I'm excited
to have you guys down there.
SPEAKER: Very soon.
And anything-- you
were mentioning
how much you love
being down there
even though you drive a very
long way to be down there.
But can you just give us some
things to look forward to
or things that you really
love about the city?
ANDREA BRIMMER: Yeah, so we were
one of the first big companies
to move back-- or to
move everybody downtown.
We had half of our
employees were there,
and then we had some people
in Southfield and Auburn Hills
and spread out all
over the place.
And we had announced that
we were going to actually
be moving out of the city,
and Mayor Duggan came to us
and said, give me two weeks to
put a plan together to keep you
guys in the city of Detroit.
And he called Dan Gilbert
and said, buy a building.
We need to keep them down here,
and he bought that building.
And we rebranded
it to Ally Center,
and we did something
really cool.
I actually got to do
the design working
with the architects
and the design firm,
and we gutted 15 floors.
And we designed every floor
like a different Detroit
neighborhood, so every one is
an homage to a different Detroit
neighborhood, and it's
a really cool way--
we sourced all the materials
from those neighborhoods.
So for instance, Cork Town,
all the wood on the floor
is from trees that had
fallen in Cork Town.
And we've got the stories
of those neighborhoods
on each one of the floors.
So we've got big murals with
the story of each one of those
neighborhoods, and it's a
great way to teach the next
generation about the city
because I grew up going
downtown all the time, but my
kids didn't, and I'm sure a lot
of the people in
this room didn't.
And it's getting people to fall
in love with the city again.
It's awesome being down there.
We pride ourselves on being one
of Detroit's favorite children.
We believe really strongly
in supporting everything
that's important to the city, so
whether it's the 4th of July--
the fireworks and
sponsoring those,
sponsoring things
with the Red Wings
and the Tigers and the
Lions, being really active
in charities and giving
back to the city,
having people volunteer.
And we've just really
immersed ourselves.
So I would tell you guys--
get out, have fun,
especially in the summer.
There's so many awesome
restaurants down there now.
Stay late.
Have a good time while
you're down there,
and throw yourself into
everything that's going on.
The vibe down there is so
creative and so awesome
right now that it's just
really, really inspiring
to be downtown.
I wouldn't want to
be anyplace else.
And wear your Detroit pride.
I actually got the old
English D tattooed on my back.
So--
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREA BRIMMER: I
had to represent.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
Well, now we're going
to turn to the audience
for any additional questions.
Anybody have any
questions to ask Andrea?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Andrea.
A lot of us actually got
our start on the agency side
as well, too, so
when you mentioned
that you were in that big
role at 35 at Campbell Ewald--
not that I was
ever in a big role.
I was no one.
But I did also start on
the creative agency side,
so I'm wondering, what
do you think now--
as a CMO who's
being brave, taking
a lot of really cool disruptive
marketing challenges-- what
do you think, from that
time on the agency side,
prepped you best and makes you
competitive and a great weapon?
ANDREA BRIMMER: No, it's
a-- that's a great question.
And I'm sure you were
somebody at the agency,
so don't sell yourself short.
So first and foremost,
I think that what
I learned on the agency side
is just about creativity,
and I know how to get great
creativity out of an agency.
That's a really
important attribute
because you guys
know, especially
in the creative world, clients
saw off all the sharp edges.
You get a really cool
idea, and by the time
it's done going through
the spanking machine,
it sucks when it comes
out the other end.
And so I'm very, very protective
of the creative process.
I really-- while I try and bring
our business partners along,
I try and really shield
the creative process,
and I think that
agencies feed off
of that protection
and that agency.
I think the second thing is the
golden gut that I talked about.
I know when I see
potential in an idea.
And you guys remember from your
agency days-- an idea's not
always perfect the
first time, but you know
when there's something there.
And a lot of clients that
just grew up on the client
side the whole time,
they either test it,
and it dies, or they
can't see the potential.
They don't know how to keep
moving it along and making
it better and making it
into something more powerful
than it was when it started.
And then I think
third, just the ability
to stand up and present
and have a presence.
And you underestimate how
important that is in business,
but when you're standing
in front of a board,
and you need to be
able to deliver,
really powerfully,
a point of view
around something that's
potentially controversial.
Or when your boss
says you're going
to present at investor
day, and you're in a room,
and you're in
front of 500 people
that are thinking about
investing in your company,
and what you say could
affect your stock price
and the way that your
company goes forward.
If you-- and
everything in between.
If you don't have
that ability to have
that presence and those
presentation skills,
it's a really tough road.
So those things were
really important to me.
I really took those
from my agency time.
Yeah, go for it.
Nothing's off bounds.
I'll tell you anything
you want to know.
AUDIENCE: Check.
So Andrea, Mike Orlando again.
Thank you again for coming in.
I feel like Ally's one of the
undervalued stories of Detroit.
Can you talk a little
bit about culture,
what you guys are doing
within the walls of Ally, what
your CEO's core objectives are?
ANDREA BRIMMER: Yeah, that's
a great question, and I agree.
I mean, part of our--
it's funny to think that 10
years has been a long time.
But it's not for a
brand, and it's not
for a brand that doesn't
spend like the brands spend
in the category.
So just our ability to
just grow sheer awareness
and get the story out
there has been tough,
and honestly, a big part
of it was because we
were so reactive in PR.
And when I took on PR
responsibility last year,
we said we're going to
really go out and start
to be really proactive,
and that's helped us a lot.
The company is an
amazing company.
Our CEO is 44 years old.
He is one of the five youngest
CEOs in the Fortune 500.
He believes very
strongly in culture.
When he goes out and
talks to investors,
and they say what is
going to separate you
from all of the other players
in the financial services
category, his first
answer is always culture.
And a lot of investors
are like, wow,
no one ever talks about culture.
And he believes very strongly
in a number of things.
He believes, first, I
think, and foremost,
in diversity and inclusion.
And I know that's a really
popular thing to say,
but it's a harder thing to do.
If you look at our C-Suite
and our executive council,
out of probably 18 people
on our executive council,
we have at least eight
women in C-Suite positions--
our chief human
resources officer,
our chief financial officer, the
president of our bank, myself.
The list goes on and on.
In fact, our CFO is
the only female CFO
in the entire banking
industry, which is staggering.
He's established
employee resource groups.
So we have 15 different
employee resource groups,
and you can join the employee
resource group that you either
identify with, or the
employee resource group
that you want to learn about.
And that's been an awesome
way investing budget and time
for people to do that.
He believes very strongly
in being purpose driven,
and we give everybody time.
We call it PTO time to--
or VTO time where they
can volunteer and do
things that are
important to them
and being a part
of the community
and doing things
really different.
So this month happens to be
financial literacy month,
and we did something
really cool for that
where, instead of
just writing a check,
we actually wrote a
children's book called
"Planet Z and the Money Tree."
And it teaches kids
about money and the fact
that it doesn't grow on trees.
And we have all of our
employees going into schools
and doing readings of "Planet
Z and the Money Tree."
And if you go on--
if you go on any of
our social pages,
you'll be able to
either download a copy,
and then we're donating hard
copies to schools as well.
And then the other
big thing that I
would say with him is
he's not a micromanager,
and nobody at Ally is.
And we let people soar
their wings and go.
We have a culture of innovation.
We're digital
financial services,
so we have to stay
on the leading edge--
maybe not always the bleeding
edge, but on the leading edge.
And you have to create
a culture of innovation,
and you have to, a, invest
in that even though everybody
is always talking about
how do I cut expenses.
So he's very good about
invest, invest, invest.
And two, he's not
afraid to let us fail.
So you can take reasonable
risks, and if you fail,
it's a good thing to learn from.
And there's no punishment
on the other end.
You don't lose your job.
You don't get a
slap on the wrists.
Even little things like
putting that Motley Crue
music on the spot-- like I said,
our board was really nervous
about it, and he was like, if
you want to do it, you do it.
You're the CMO.
Good or bad, it's on
you, and I support you.
So I think those are the things
that are happening at Ally.
It's an awesome company.
Weird going through
these agency pitches
right now as I mentioned.
For me, I think the next
big thing I want to do
is just create this
awakening around how
great the company is, how
differentiated our product is,
and just get people to pay
attention to their money again.
And that's what we're
really trying to do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDREA BRIMMER: Yep.
SPEAKER: Anyone else?
ANDREA BRIMMER: All right.
SPEAKER: Thank
you again, Andrea.
ANDREA BRIMMER: Thank you, guys.
Thanks for having me.